Hey, welcome to day 23. We are in "40 Days of Holiness." We're collecting
metaphors for holiness throughout the scripture.
Metaphors are word pictures, capture our imaginations,
teach us what holiness is, and inspire us to long for it. All right?
Today's metaphor is
the completing of the project of holiness that we started at the new
birth. All right? So we're in the last few verses of 2 Corinthians 6
and going into chapter 7. So this is written to the
Corinthian Christians. Now, are these people holy already?
Yes, they are. In 2 Corinthians 1:2, God
calls them saints. You remember what that word is?
We studied this in the past. It's "hagioi," right? It's the holy ones.
So they are holy, right? With that in mind,
let's take a look at what Paul says to these saints, these holy ones.
He starts off with promises of what holiness in God's
people does for our relationship with God.
6:14, "Do not be yoked together
with unbelievers. For what do righteousness and wickedness have in common?
Or what fellowship can light have with darkness?"
Verse 15, "What harmony is there between Christ and Belial?" Which is a word
that means worthless. It's a nickname for Satan in this case.
"Or what does a believer have in common with an unbeliever?
What agreement is there between the temple of God and idols?
For we are the temple of the living God.
As God has said, 'I will live with them and walk among
them, and I will be their God, and they will
be my people.'
Therefore," verse 17, "'Come out from them and be
separate,' says the Lord." You hear that holiness, that separation?
"Touch no unclean thing, and I will receive you.
And," he quotes from the Old Testament, "'I will be a Father to you, and you will
be my sons and daughters,' says the Lord
Almighty." Now he's inspiring them to remember
what holiness does in connecting you to
a holy God. Holiness is hated by
wickedness, and wickedness should be hated by holiness.
It's like mixing light with darkness, righteousness
mixing with wickedness, oil mixing with water. It just doesn't work.
Idols in the temple of the true God.
Jesus mixing with Satan. So you get the
picture here. He's saying they are two vastly different things.
Now, when he starts talking about these things, he's going to give them
promises now. Promise number one is the full presence of
God restored. In verse 16, he says, "I will live with
them and walk among them," like Adam in the Garden of Eden.
Promise number two is a full acceptance by God.
In verse 17, he says, "I will receive you."
Promise three is full experience of sonship.
In verse 18, he says, "I will be a father, and you will be my
sons and daughters." Then in chapter 7, verse
1, he transitions. Listen. "Since we have these promises,
dear friends,
let us put into practice
all that God has promised and provided." Right? Listen.
"Let us
purify ourselves from everything that
contaminates body and spirit, perfecting
holiness out of reverence for God." Do you notice that he
says, "Everything that contaminates body and spirit"?
If you've sinned against God, and he gives you clear direction
about what to do, take care of it. Get rid of it, confess it,
forsake it, kick it out of your life.
And if you're doing something in your body that's wrong,
this is the time to take care of that. We have promises.
We have a hope. We have a Savior. Now, I want to bring this
out as clearly as I can.
In the moment of salvation, God sanctifies us and
purifies us and starts us on a path of
complete holiness, a fulfilling of
everything Jesus died to provide.
And this is based on the promises of God, his complete provision
for us. But there comes this moment where you realize that this
path of holiness is taking you to a place
where you start finding some ways in which your spirit is
corrupted by self.
It's as if you were twisted or scarred by something, and that
twisting, that bending in, that deformity,
is causing an impurity in your spirit.
And this call to cleanse ourselves, not just of old acts of sin from the
past, but to kick out, repudiate, reject,
renounce the portion of corruption of
spirit that was brought upon us by our connection
with Adam's nature.
So, "Let us cleanse ourselves" doesn't mean that we
do the work ourselves. It means that we should take
advantage of the provisions God has made for our cleansing.
God has provided it all, so don't walk away and
assume it's hopeless and you've just got to live with it.
We've got promises. We have promises. Don't walk away.
Let these promises inspire you to seek to perfect holiness,
to complete and finish the work, to bring
it to its fullness, is what the word means.
Interesting. So he calls them to complete,
to
bring to fullness that. And in 2 Corinthians 8:6, he uses
this. He says, "Since Titus has earlier made a beginning, let me
urge you to bring to completion this offering you started." So he's like,
"You've started taking up this collection.
I want you to bring it to completion." In the same way, he says, "God has
started by making you saints. Now let's complete the work.
Let's complete the saints. Let's bring the holy ones
to an entirely new level of holiness.
Let's get rid of that last filthiness." God has
provided this. Don't walk away. We have all his
promises,
so let's take advantage of the blood of cleansing and have
everything that it provides for us.
Complete the project that God has started in you.
That's what 2 Corinthians 7:6 and 7 is teaching
us to do, and that's the metaphor for today for holiness in your heart
and your life and mine.
We'll see you tomorrow.